hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer lumen tour
aus dem hotel wo ich zur zeit bin in
österreich ich muss mal gucken dass das
riecht ja einigermaßen dass mich das an
leuchtet weil das alles total blöd steht
hier eigentlich ich habe es ja schon mal
sehr vielen videos angedeutet ich bin
über weihnachten in österreich so sieht
übrigens der ausblick aus wenn ihr das
mal sehen möchtet hier schaut euch das
mal an
olé liegt schnee nicht allerdings mal
ein bisschen warten so mal seht ihr
schon der schnee dies auf dem weg dahin
ist einfach gar kein schnee mehr
er ist auf dem weg wirklich zu
verschwinden also irgendwie die tage
soll zwar nach normalen regen einen
schneeschauer geben aber ich meine
dieser ausblick aus dem hotel ist
einfach der der kultclub gedacht jetzt
sollte so zum 24
ihr hattet ja vor zwei tagen ein juni
wohl zu fragen beantwortet habe deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht heute am 24
mach ich mal ein video wo ich euch das
hier zeige wie das hier überhaupt alles
aussieht wo ich nicht befindet sich
kleines zimmer aber ich das rad einfach
eine kleine room to hoch hier auf dem
konto und damit fangen wir jetzt
eigentlich auch mal an das ganze beginnt
hier mit der eingangstür also hier ist
diese tür da kann man drauf gehen und
wieder reingehen hier bin ich gerade
hier in der zürichsee total fertig was
eigentlich nicht so viel geplant hat
hier ist der schalter womit man die
komplette elektrizität in diesem raum
aktivieren oder deaktivieren kann hier
sind jacken schals besten und so weiter
meine shows die stadt an rucksack vom
hotel sondern ding das man sagen kann
hänge ich spring packung kommt man nicht
rein oder haye kommt man noch mal sauber
und sorge ist unser toller fernseher auf
dem heute abend erst mal schön
irgendeinen film geschaut wird
jetzt kommt er gar nicht klappen
fokussieren hier der ist von einer marke
die ich euch jetzt nicht hallo manchmal
fokussieren bitte kriegt er das doch
noch hin
das ist von einer marke die ich nicht
zeigen manchmal sonst kann wieder jeder
an höhe wie viel kriegst du dafür dass
du in apple laptop zeigst 20 millionen
vielleicht so jedenfalls ist hier halt
dieser fernseher und hier ist so eine
kleine kiste die kann man um
wenn man möchte die kann man dann auch
noch mal um treten nähe also die lässt
man eigentlich dass du jetzt hält ihr
noch woher kommt eigentlich so wenn man
ihnen die wäsche hat oder so kann man
das eher einstellen weil die waschen
hier halt auch vom hotel aber ich habe
mir jetzt so viele sachen mitgenommen
dass ich das glaube ich nicht nutzen
werde
hier ist der kleine tisch wo ich gleich
das video schneiden werde hier bin ich
auch zur zeit meine facharbeit am
schreiben für die universität
da will die das fach arbeit da ist die
verarbeitung ist noch was für die arbeit
im bach und andere sachen da werde ich
das ganze gleich hierfür ein bisschen
versuchen zu schneiden irgendwie
provisorischen auch noch eine magic
mouse mitgenommen von meinem neuen imac
5 warum hast du jeden einkauf weil ich
kratzt aber ein richtig viele leute die
einfach wieder so rum gerettet haben so
hat der windows rechner
nee ich möchte das was schön aussieht
was eine gute qualität hat und so einen
windows rechner
ich hab mal geschaut 4k bildschirme die
kosten ja einfach wenn man sich in 4k
bildschirm kaufkosten die bildschirme
schon 2000 euro und ich hab den ganzen
pc und der s5 karte kostet eben die 3000
euro also 30 da nehme ich lieber mehr
geld in hand habt was preis stabiles
unten ein mac und den schönen computer
als irgendwie so ein ding was total den
heftigen lüfter hat und strom verbraucht
wie 10 waschmaschinen und nach zwei
tagen 400 euro weniger wert ist also das
ist meine persönliche meinung dazu ihr
könnt von mir aus in die kommentare
schreiben
windows ist ja viel besser aber ich weiß
nicht ich mag apple oh das ist dann auf
jeden fall hier so dieser arbeitsbereich
dingsbums da ist hier ist stuhl wo ich
mich gleich hinsetzen
so sieht das ganze aus das hier ist wohl
ein cd-spieler denke ich mal
ich wusste gar nicht dass so etwas noch
gibt in heutigen welt aber hängt also
das ist der bereich für die technik geht
dann haben wir hier meine tasche wo
sachen von mir drin sind wir wissen da
drin mit umschlägen collegeblock bücher
schreibt sachen zum lernen halt hier ist
meine tasche so die sachen drin sind die
ich mit raffiniert ist die krims krams
ecke also hier habe ich eine hose die
ich gestern hatte hier liegt meine
badehose
ist meine boxershort die auch gewaschen
muss meine jacke liegt darunter avi
solider grundlage
jedenfalls ist hier soll dieser typisch
ist diese typische hotel tischlein soja
kommen wie eine fernsehzeitung dass es
unser programm da habt ihr zwei äpfel
wenn ihr die es bis zu 1000 euro
bezahlen und das ist quasi nähe zum
außenbereich komme ich einfach gleich am
ende weg um erst mal hier
ach da ist übrigens auch noch einen
koffer da ist ein bisschen hier ist
übrigens dieses ganze hier ist überhaupt
nicht geplant ich wollte ich jetzt
einfach noch mal zeigen das ist auch so
ein knopf
damit kann ich überall das licht
ausstellen wenn ich diesen knopf hier
unten drücke dann nimmt sich das alles
ab also ich drücke den jetzt mal schaut
mal dann geht ja alles so aufgewühlte
stimmung wenn ich dann wieder hier drauf
drücke dann geht das ganze wieder so ein
bisschen heller und wenn ich die taste
dann links drücke geht diese lampe hier
an und dann kann ich so lesen wenn ich
lesen würde jetzt dann das bett hier
liegen auch so sachen drauf jemanden
gästekarte ein bettlaken die kissen und
so mein schlaf die stadt das von you
tube t shirt von ihnen so einer
veranstaltung oder so das kenne ich
eigentlich immer mein handy osten iphone
6 sowie sie hat kein android
ich sehe schon wieder kommt meine damen
und herren dann ist das badezimmer der
ist ein bademantel der iss drei xl der
geht mir bis zu meinen füßen der ist
echt krass also bin jetzt nicht der
kleinste mensch aber dass der elfmal
bademantel echt so krass riesig ist
hätte ich nicht gedacht ganz dagegen
sind allerdings diese teile also ich
habe schuhgröße 44 jahre alt und wenn
ihr mal seht ich gehe da na ja ein
bisschen darüber hat es ganz cool und
reißt das hier ja das ist halt das klo
allerdings finde ich ganz cool man kann
hier wirklich so alle schieben ich kann
hier so die tür ist zu schieben so die
ist jetzt so komplett zu und dann kann
ich jetzt mein handtuch anhängen über
die heizung und das coole an dieser tür
hier ist ich kann die einerseits so
verschieben wenn ich hier in der dusche
kindern ist dazu und wenn ich packen
wenn er nämlich die tür und schiebt die
hierhin und an citigroup das war ein
bisschen zu schnell und dann seht ihr
allerdings schon
dann ist der straße abgeriegelt und hier
ist auch mit milchglas
also das hier ist die das haus und das
ist die dusche dies extrem cool weil das
kommt einfach so von rudis bisschen
schief übrigens auch nur eine ahnung
jedenfalls kann man da halt einfach dann
das wasser kommt quasi von oben runter
geplätscher ist es richtig cool und dann
ist hier das badezimmer wo wir hier so
sachen drin haben wieso einen
eingebauten föhn handtücher haben wir
hier reinpasst wirkung von ronal die
zahnbürste
ein deodorant body spray mein parfüm
oder eau de toilette oder was auch immer
ein unterschied des und mein bugs da
steht hier alles und noch als lehrer und
zu ein paar kranz sachen und sonst da
bin ich übrigens sonst war's das auch
schon von dem badezimmer ich finde das
aber megacool design einfach das hier so
dieses ganze zimmer so ein bisschen
rustikaler mit dem holz nicht gegen die
scheibe glaubt es hat dieses hotel echt
ganz cool hinbekommen dass alles
miteinander so zu verbinden dass hier
ist dieser spiegel wenn man also euro
das ist dieser wenn man da so drin ist
dann wird das tun aber wenn man weiter
weg ist dann ist das wunsch auf fragt
mich nicht wie das geht oder ich brauche
das auch nicht jedenfalls habe ich
jedoch meine ganzen sachen drin wenn ich
immer auf mache habe ich hier meine
mädchen drehen wenn ich hunger habe ich
hier meinen unterhosen gehen hier seine
anderen sachen die ich du immer an hier
die liegen hier halt so drin und ich bin
hier wieder viel zu laut ich will nicht
sagen dass ist das dann schon mit der
kultur war ich meine was hat das gibt's
ja noch aus haben das bett dies
badezimmer den schulbereich und den
arbeitsbereich und das da hinten
ach ich könnte ich wollte ja auch noch
mal kurz draußen gehen hier und auf den
außen balkon zeigen also so sieht das
aus wenn man nach draußen geht und diese
tür aufgeschoben hat da ist dass man
links von mir da steiner rechts von mir
hier befinde ich mich und da ist die
kleine chill ecke wo man wenn man möchte
das ein oder andere tränklein trinken
kann ja und so sieht der ausblick von
diesem hotel dann aus also von dem
zimmer in dem ich bin ich finds megacool
richtig geil also sind jetzt nur noch
ganz ganz kurze zeit da wenn ihr das
video seht fahren wir sogar am nächsten
tag schon ab glaube ich aber es ist auf
jeden fall richtig cool ich habe auch
schon 111 ii hier gemacht und
hochgeladene neben hotel glaube ich auf
instagram bisher und würde ich sagen
meine lieben freunde ich hoffe das setzt
mich fokussiert nicht im hintergrund ja
das klappt sogar ich bin ein bisschen
dunkel
ich würde sagen dass war es mit der ruhe
die man ja einfach extrem kaltes ihr
seht ja schon liegt schnee es sind
glaube ich und ich hoffe bald legen
es sind glaube ich zwei grad oder ein
gras oder so ich werde mir jetzt wieder
meinen bademantel anziehen und irgendwie
fitness machen oder irgendwie nimmt
wellnessbereich gehen oder mich
massieren lassen und natürlich erstmal
jetzt noch jedes video schneiden
ich würde allerdings sagen es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich definitiv
über eine bewertung freuen wenn ihr
maria leipold ich bin zurzeit ich habe
ja gesagt so ein bisschen am gucken ob
ich das jetzt wieder auf lukas film
übertragen oder hier das real life mache
aber ich sehe einfach dass hier das real
life auch extrem cool ankommt deswegen
weil ich das ganze wieder hier zu machen
ich weiß nicht was haltet ihr davon mal
dass wir so eine eu perspektive
aber na ja ich würde es mal so angesehen
und dann eventuell in einem anderen
video wieder